a primera vista podría pensarse que es
una gran gala o la alfombra roja de
algún festival Pero no es así estos
jóvenes de 17 y 18 años pronto se
graduarán de la secundaria pero primero
celebrarán una noche inolvidable con sus
amigos y compañeros de clase
[Aplausos]
el baile de graduación
la escuela hizo todo lo posible para que
sus alumnos celebren su graduación por
todo lo alto con casino barra de dulces
Dj y regalos para todos
[Música]
el comité que financia el baile cobra 35
dólares por entrada pero los recuerdos
no tienen precio
este baile de graduación costó unos
$9,000 creo que habrían estado felices
con una fiesta un poco más sencilla
pero nosotros somos los que presionamos
para hacerla lo mejor posible
que sus hijos tengan el mejor baile de
graduación Ese es el objetivo de
millones de padres estadounidenses entre
los meses de abril y mayo limosinas
vestidos de noche joyas Esta es también
una gran temporada para muchos negocios
entre ellos las tiendas de vestidos
[Música]
Niki White madre soltera Acompaña a su
hija a elegir el vestido perfecto
su presupuesto es de 300 dólares pero
podría ser de más
ella es quien Escoge yo compro lo que
quiera llevarse incluyendo el peinado el
maquillaje y Las joyas Nicky gastará más
de mil dólares en su hija
Más o menos lo mismo en su hijo para
poder costear los gastos de sus dos
hijos esta madre tuvo que conseguir un
segundo trabajo me alegra hacer esto por
ellos y tendría tres trabajos solo para
que tuvieran un buen baile de graduación
para las tiendas de ropa formal la
temporada de bailes de graduaciones
crucial para sus ingresos obtenemos el
70% de los ingresos del año en los dos
meses de la temporada de bailes de
graduación lo que ayuda es que los
padres no vienen con un presupuesto fijo
solo quieren que sus hijos se vean bien
el servicio de limusina de también
prospera durante esta temporada su
limusina está completamente reservada
para transportar a los estudiantes a sus
bailes de graduación Es un negocio muy
rentable si aceptamos demasiadas
reservas estamos en problemas
en este caso tenemos otras empresas que
nos ayudan pero es un negocio muy
rentable
llevar a los jóvenes en limusina su
baile y después de vuelta a sus casas
cuesta 600 dólares
una cifra que no desmotiva a los padres
quienes parecen disfrutar de la
experiencia tanto como sus hijos
pensamos en hacer algo entretenido para
ello
con la limusina una pequeña alfombra
roja
No queríamos que el día pasara sin más
queríamos que fuera memorable una vez
terminada la celebración oficial la
mayoría de los estudiantes asistirán a
otras fiestas y algunos incluso pasarán
el fin de semana celebrando su baile de
graduación esta industria mueve
alrededor de 4 mil millones de dólares
en Estados Unidos